hmm Wow they all taste like fish they
all taste like fish to me
I ate sushi about three or four times a
month cheap sushi has that fishy smell
where it's expensive sushi just tastes
really fresh I'm a professional sushi
eater I don't use chopsticks I use my
fingers and dip the fish side in the soy
sauce first put it in my mouth upside
down to holding enough you don't bite
sushi when the right sushi I go like mmm
because it's so good I've been in Japan
so I think I know what I'm talking about
when it comes to sushi thank you these
get out of here whoa hmm this one's a
little milky it's got some it's a little
translucent this one has like a lot of
cuts on them that's mostly good or bad
visually I would say this one is not
like these two sounds a little stringy
err they went cheap on the rice on this
but I feel like there's more fish I'm
kind of falling apart this one has a
brighter orange color
[Music]
this is not expensive with the rice we
can tell it is not expensive rice the
rice is really cold and put together
kind of ly fresh I feel like this is a
little more expensive there's texture
but then it melts in my mouth afterwards
I'm gonna try to middle one now see hmm
very soft now I'm confused
this is big so I thought it was not
expensive but it's very soft the rice is
very soft too that's a very buttery
that's good it's fresh I think I don't
know could we get back on the second
bite you here this one's very buttery
now this one's very fatty gosh this is
hard
[ __ ] this is way harder than I thought
this just could be just a video of me
like enjoying sushi that's the cheap one
the one I had here nothing this one has
a better balance it's hard I know I'm
really confident about this it's one of
the cheapest the big ones that looked
weird was the medium that's the most
expensive well I'm gonna say this one
was the most expensive just because this
was a Prius looking one cheapest
expensive medium [ __ ] eat sushi I'm a
basic white [ __ ] who loves salmon sushi
oh okay well the middle one looked weird
I don't know one like look did not look
anything like the other one I feel both
embarrassed and relieved because I guess
I only deserve cheap sushi yeah like if
in 20 years my kids can have salmon
sushi will be so pissed so [ __ ] clean
up the ocean
[Music]